well more than 60 million people are
expected to shop online this year for
cyber monday in addition to major
retailers many small businesses are
getting in on the holidays discounts
kate houston is live from therapy
boutique near sahara and fort apache
with the latest kate
yes well due to the pandemic many of our
local businesses had to go online to
reach customers and that's why there
will be more local discounts this year
than ever before and here at therapy
boutique they sell women's clothing
accessories and even some stocking
stuffers right now that you're looking
at now they're promoting big sales
online for cyber monday and applying
that in store as well
therapy boutique owner jessica boone
says it's been an interesting shopping
season she's noticed many customers are
shopping online due to convenience or
not wanting to be in crowds but there
has also been a push to shop local in
store due to how the pandemic has hurt
small businesses this year boone started
holiday discounts up to 60 percent off
in store and online a week ahead of
black friday to stay competitive it just
makes it easier when we can kind of get
ahead of what the big guys are doing and
for us as a small business
as difficult as shipping has been lately
we can still pivot easier than one of
the big stores when they
have to take longer boone says shipping
has been a challenge which is why there
are still some slightly out of season
products with that said she says it's
much easier to work around since they
order smaller quantities and she has the
ability to drive out of state to pick up
products
and despite shipping concerns and supply
chain issues fedex and usps say they
will be able to handle the volume of
shipments this holiday season however
they do recommend that you get those
shipments out as early as you can
reporting live from therapy boutique
kate houston live local now